.
WE'LL COME BACK IN A FEW MINUTES
AS MORE EVENTS UNFOLD.
>>> LET'S TURN TO THIS BATTLE
FIELD SHIFT IN UKRAINE.
UKRAINIAN FORCES RECAPTURED
NEARLY 1200 SQUARE MILES OF
TERRITORY NORTHERN EAST WERE
PART OF THE COUNTRY AND IT'S
HAPPENED IN LESS THAN TWO WEEKS.
THAT'S MORE LAND THAN RUSSIA HAS
BEEN ABLE TO CONQUER OVER THE
LAST FIVE MONTHS.
>> UKRAIIAN FORCES TAKING BACK
AND LIBERATING SEVERAL TOWNS
RECEIVING HUGS FROM LOCALS AND
LITTLE RESISTANCE FROM
RETREATING RUSSIAN TROOPS.
BUT DESPITE THE GAINS, RUSSIA
LAUNCHED NEW AIR STRIKES IN THE
REGION TODAY.
MELISSA BELL IS IN KHARKIV FOR
US.
HELP US UNDERSTAND THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING AT THIS HOUR.
>> Reporter: WELL, REALLY QUITE
EXTRAORDINARY TO SAY NOT LEAST
FOR THE PEOPLE IN THE VILLAGES
WHO HAVE BEEN LIBERATED AFTER
SIX MONTHS OF OCCUPATION AND
BEAR IN MIND IN THOSE VILLAGES
WHERE IT'S SUFFICIENTLY SECURE
THAT INVESTIGATORS CAN GET IN,
SPEAK TO THE PEOPLE AND WORK OUT
WHAT HAS GONE ON.
WE SAW SOME OF THEM DO THAT
YESTERDAY.
WHAT THEY'RE FINDING SADLY IS
SIGNS OF POSSIBLE WAR CRIMES,
INVESTIGATIONS HAVE BEEN OPENED.
YOU'LL THINK BACK, RUSSIAN
TROOPS HAD BEEN IN THOSE PARTS
FOR A MONTH.
HERE THEY HAVE BEEN FOR SIX
MONTHS.
OVER THE COURSE OF THE NEXT FEW
DAYS AND WEEKS YOU'LL BE HEARING
A LOT MORE ABOUT THAT.
THE PLACES WHERE THEY CAN GET IN
THAT ARE SUFFICIENTLY SECURE
THAT SAY THE POLICE AND WAR
CRIMES INVESTIGATORS CAN GO AND
START THEIR JOB ARE REALLY JUST
AT THE VERY BEGINNING OF THIS
EXTRAORDINARY FAST MOVING
EASTERN OFFENSIVE.
IT HAS CONTINUED.
IT BEGAN LAST WEEK.
THOSE EARLY SUCCESSES, NOW THE
SUBJECT OF INVESTIGATIONS AND
RESEARCH BUT AS YOU MOVE FURTHER
EASTWARDS TO KEY TOWNS, YOU
REALIZE THAT ACTUALLY EVEN IN
THE PLACES WHERE THE UKRAINIAN
FLAG HAS BEEN RAISED AND HARD TO
GET TO THEM, THERE IS STILL
FIGHTING GOING ON.
WE MANAGED TO GET TO THE
UKRAINIAN FLAG RAISED THERE 24
HOURS BEFORE.
HAVE A LOOK AT WHAT WE CAME
ACROSS.
A FIRST ARTILLERY STRIKE, TOO
CLOSE FOR COMFORT, THEN A
SECOND.
MUCH CLOSER.
>> SO RUSSIAN FORCES ARE TRYING
TO KEEP HOLD OF THOSE KEY
STRATEGIC TOWNS IN PARTS BUT AS
YOU SAY, WHAT'S EXTRAORDINARY IS
WATCH THAT ADVANCE CONTINUE.
WHAT WE'VE SEEN OVER THE COURSE
OF THE DAY IS MORE UKRAINIAN
GAINS SO FAR SOUTH THAT
UKRAINIAN FORCES HAVE NOW
CROSSED THE DONETSK RIVER AND
TAKEN A VILLAGE TO THE SOUTH AND
THAT'S EXTREMELY SIGNIFICANT.
ADVANCES CONTINUING FAST BUT
IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER NOT
AT NO COST.
THESE ARE EXTREMELY DIFFICULT
BATTLES IN SOME OF THOSE KEY
TOWNS.
BUT STILL, THOSE FORCES MANAGING
TO MOVE FORWARD AND I THINK NO
ONE, NOT AT LEAST THE UKRAINIANS
ANTICIPATED THIS EASTERN
OFFENSIVE WOULD BE AS SUCCESSFUL
AS IT'S BEEN AND PART OF THAT IS
THE CLEVERNESS WITH WHICH THE
COMMUNICATION WAS DEALT WITH.
REMEMBER, THEY LAUNCHED THE
COUNTER OFFENSIVE TO THE SOUTH
AT THE END OF AUGUST, KEPT THAT
UNDER TIGHT WRAPS, LED NOT TO
THE ONES HERE IN THE KHARKIV
REGION IN THE EAST AND IT'S THAT
ONE THAT THE RUSSIAN FORCES WERE
GUESSING WERE SIMPLY NOT READY
FOR AND IT IS THAT ONE THAT IS
MAKING THE MOST EXTRAORDINARY
PROGRESS AS YOU SAY TAKING BACK
SO MANY PARTS OF THE COUNTRY
TAKEN BY THE RUSSIANS IN APRIL
AND MAY.
NOW, APPARENTLY, BACK MANY OF
THEM IN THE HANDS OF UKRAINIAN
FORCES, ALISON AND VICTOR?
>> WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT THE
CONDITIONS OF THESE LIBERATED
TOWNS AFTER MONTHS OF BEING
UNDER THE CONTROL OF RUSSIAN
FORCES?
>> Reporter: THE ONES YOU CAN
GET TO ARE FEW AND FAR BETWEEN
AT THE BEGINNING OF WHERE THE
EASTERN OFFENSE BEGAN A FEW DAYS
AGO.
ONE OF THE ONES WE VISITED
YESTERDAY WE HEARD FROM KHARKIV
PROSECUTORS, WE WATCHED THE BODY
OF A CIVILIAN DUG UP, SIGNS OF
TORTURE KILLED BY RUSSIAN FORCES
IN THE FIRST DAYS OF THE WAR.
IT'S THAT PICTURE OF WHAT'S GONE
ON ON THAT SIDE OF THE LINE WAS
MAINTAINED FOR SO LONG.
NOT JUST ANGRY TROOPS CARRYING
OUT UNSPEAKABLE CRIMES AGAINST
CIVILIANS BUT A MUCH MORE
SYSTEMATIC ATTEMPT TO CONTROL AN
ENTIRE POPULATION WITH ALL KINDS
OF ABUSES AGAINST CIVILIANS,
PART OF A STRATEGY BY MOSCOW TO
KEEP THESE TOWNS ON THAT SIDE OF
THE LINE AND DRAW THEM INTO THE
RUSSIAN FEDERATION AND WHAT
PROSECUTORS IN KYIV ARE SAYING
THEY'VE BEEN HEARING ABOUT AND
INVESTIGATING CRIMES FROM THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE LINE A MUCH
MORE SIMATIC ATTEMPT TO PUT IN
PLACE A TOTALITARIAN REGIME,
CLEAN OUT THE AREAS ENTIRELY
WITH ALL THE BRUTALITY YOU CAN
IMAGINE.
>> MELISSA BELL IN KHARKIV THERE
FOR US WITH FANTASTIC REPORTING.
LET'S BRING IN PETER WHO SERVED
IN MOSCOW FROM 2012 TO 2014 AS
THE U.S. SENIOR DEFENSE OFFICIAL
FOR THE RUSSIAN FEDERATION.
WELCOME BACK.
ARE YOU SURPRISED?
WE HEARD ABOUT THE LOGISTICAL
AND MORAL CHALLENGES OF RUSSIAN
FORCES BUT 1200 SQUARE MILES IN
JUST A MATTER OF WEEKS THE
UKRAINIAN FORCES HAD BEEN ABLE
TO RETAKE.
DOES THAT SURPRISE YOU?
>> I AM SURPRISED AT THE SCALE
AND THE SPEED OF WHAT LOOKS TO
BE ALMOST A MELTDOWN OF RUSSIAN
FORCES IN AND AROUND THE KHARKIV
AREA AND THIS THING COULD BE
CONTAGIOUS.
THE WORD GETS OUT.
I -- YES, SAYING THAT, WE SAW
HOW EFFECTIVE UKRAIIANS HAVE
BEEN AS FIGHTERS.
THEIR WILL AND PASSION FOR THEIR
NATION THAT REALLY, REALLY
EMERGED AND A LOT OF THE NEW
WEAPONS THAT HAVE COME IN TO
SUPPORT BUT YES, THIS IS RATHER
EXTRAORDINARY.
I WOULD PUT A CAUTIONARY TALE, I
ALWAYS WORRY ABOUT OVER
EXTENSION AND THEN LEAVING
YOURSELF VULNERABLE.
NO.
THIS IS QUITE SOMETHING.
>> SO IN TERMS OF OVER
EXTENSION, I KNOW YOU SAY THAT
THE SOUTH IS KEY.
IT'S IMPORTANT YOU CALL IT AND
MELISSA BELL, OUR REPORTER THERE
SAID THEY'VE MADE REMARKABLE
GAINS ON THE DONETSK REGION.
WHAT WOULD OVER EXTENSION LOOK
LIKE?
I MEAN, CAN THEY NOW START
TRYING TO TAKE THE SOUTH?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT AGAIN, WE
HAVE -- OR THE UKRAINIANS HAVE,
I BELIEVE THEY NEED TO
AGGRESSIVELY BUT CAREFULLY
CONTINUE TO PUSH UP IN KHARKIV
BUT ALSO NOW CONTINUING THEIR
PRESSURE THAT THEY'RE PUTTING
DOWN ALONG THE KHARSON AREA,
THEY NEED TO PUSH.
THEY JUST NEED TO BE NOT OVER
EXTEND BUT AGAIN, THERE IS AN
ASPECT OF THE RUSSIAN DEFENSE
ESPECIALLY UP IN KHARKIV AND HOW
IT NOW IS BEGINNING TO HIT
RUSSIAN POSITIONS LINED IN
DONETSK OF KICKING A ROTTING
DOOR DOWN, SO WE REMEMBER ONE
THING IN 2014 AND 2015 AND I
THINK UKRAINIANS REMEMBER IT
WELL, THEY DID HAVE A COUNTER
OFFENSIVE IN DONBAS AND OVER
EXTENDED AND THE RUSSIANS WERE
ABLE TO PUSH THEM OUT.
I THINK ALL OF THIS IS A SWIRL,
THE CHAOS OF WAR BUT THE
UKRAINIANS CLEARLY INITIATIVE,
MOTIVATION, WILL TO FIGHT AND
THE RUSSIANS SHOW NONE OF THAT.
>> GENERAL, DO YOU THINK THIS
CONTINUED TERRITORIAL LOSS MAKES
A SINGULAR PUNCTUATED ESCALATION
ATTACK MORE LIKELY TO COME FROM
THE RUSSIANS TO TRY TO SAVE FACE
HERE?
>> THIS IS TURNING OUT TO BE
REALLY ROTTEN ENDEAVOR NO MATTER
WHAT THE DISINFORMATION AND
NARRATIVE OUT OF THE KREMLIN IS
FOR THE RUSSIANS, FOR MOSCOW,
FOR THE MILITARY.
THIS IS EMBARRASSING.
IT'S HUMILIATING.
AND YES, IT IS NOW IN MY MIND
BECOME -- THERE WERE TWO FIGHTS,
VICTOR.
ONE IS FOR THE SURVIVAL OF
UKRAINIAN STATE AS A FREE
MINDED -- LOOKS LIKE IT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN.
THE OTHER ONE IS WHAT IS THE
KREMLIN AND THAT STATE AND THIS
IS IMPORTANT, THE -- YOU KNOW,
THE WOLVES OR BANG AND WE'RE
SEEING PROTEST.
THERE IS DISGRUNTLEMENT IN THE
MILITARY.
THE CHECHEN STRONG MAN IS OUT
PUBLICLY.
THIS DOES CONCERN ME BECAUSE
THERE IS A BACKED IN THE CORNER
ASPECT OF THIS THING.
THESE THINGS ARE CONTAGIOUS.
IF IT CONTINUES THIS WAY AND YOU
GET MORE AND MORE RUSSIANS, YOU
JUST READ A CNN REPORT 18
PREVENTION LEADERS HAVE COME OUT
AGAINST THE REGIME.
THIS IS CASCADING.
THIS COULD MAKE THE KREMLIN
DESPERATE AND THEY DO HAVE A
RANGE OF POSSIBILITIES OF MAJOR,
MAJOR, YOU KNOW, INCREASING
VIOLENCE UP TO, YOU KNOW,
BRANDISHING.
NOBODY WANTS IT BUT BRANDISHING
IN THE VERY, VERY WORST CASE A
NUCLEAR BACKOFF WE HAVE NUKES
ASPECT OF THIS.
>> ONE OF THE PARTS YOU TALKED
ABOUT SEEMS SURPRISING OF THE 18
MUNICIPAL DEPUTIES FEELING FREE
TO CRITICIZE AND C